on the northern coast of the Greek
island of Lesbos word comes that a boat
full of migrants has been spotted the
evolving crisis and grief
they've been escorted to shore by
Spanish rescuers after a failed
interception by the Turkish Coast Guard
24 people 14 Afghan is and 10 Egyptians
including a number of young children now
they are safe after being trussed to sea
by smugglers very difficult journey and
the Turks beat us a lot by hand by foot
they kick us on the ground
Europe is divided and troubled over its
attitude to migration but these people
aren't giving up on the hope of being
accepted what do you expect you expect
to live you can't live in peace in Egypt
Christians most of the people are
Muslims you must understand that Europe
cannot take in all of the people of the
world
I know I know Europe cannot take all of
the river in the world but I I feel not
peaceful in my country it has been a
journey of just six nautical miles a
route Europe was desperate to close down
if you thought the eu-turkey deal had
stopped the flow of migrants arriving
between Turkey and Greece it simply
hasn't on this one Greek island alone up
to a hundred people a day are arriving
wasn't the turkey deal supposed to stop
this it's a question I can answer but it
hasn't stopped people arriving in Greece
has it it has enough
there are an increasing number of women
and children making the perilous journey
on this route Herkimer group and with no
Greek officials in sight the welcome
here was entirely provided by
international volunteers but after so
many have come before them the reception
in the rest of Europe may not be so worn
Lisa Holland Sky News on the Greek
island of Lesbos